welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation
titled eliminate temperature sensitivity
and lyophilization technology it's my
pleasure to introduce you to amy webster
a custom manufacturing service leader
with genomics and diagnostic solutions
at sativa
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end of our presentation
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter amy webster i will now
turn the presentation over to her
welcome amy
so thank you very much for the kind
introduction we're
here today to talk about how to
eliminate temperature sensitivity with
lyophilizing
localization technology so first off
we're going to give you a brief
introduction as to who i am and who
saitiva is
and then we go through the principles of
loyolization
how you would do it what you can use it
for and why you would do it
and i can then go through a case study
for you
and give you some further information
and links to
videos of the site and then go through
any questions
so introduction um my name's amy
and i work at the cardiff manufacturing
site
for saitva in the uk
i am part of a team called the
customized solutions team and
we're a team of seven dedicated
scientists
and we have we are entirely dedicated to
customer projects and we have no r d
responsibilities
we have five main services what we call
plates conjugation contract
manufacturing
custom biology and localization
so the contract manufacturing
we can take your process and we can
manufacture in-house
plates we've got a range of filter
plates that we can put custom membranes
in
contract uh custom biology we can take
any of our catalog products
and customize it to your requirements
conjugation we have a range of magnetic
beads that we can conjugate antibodies
or oligos to
and lyo stable is our freeze drying and
localization service which we're going
to go through in more detail
so localization how do you do it
what can you do it to and why would you
do it so lyophilization
is a stabilizing technique which takes a
liquid
freezes it sublimes all the moist or the
water from it
and leaves you with a solid classy cake
the with the cake being a solid the
reagents in it can no longer move
and there is there should be no side
reactions and no degradation occurring
in the solid state
benefits of lyophilization so why would
you want to layoffalice
one of the big advantages of
lyophilization is ambient storage and
shipment
this means that you no longer have to
ship enzymes and
other reagents around the world on dry
ice and ambient conditions
everything can go in the same package
it can be stored at point of use at
ambience you don't need a minus 80 and
-20
and a fridge at the same time
and this saves not only in dry ice and
benefiting the environment but also as
the shipper it saves an awful lot of
money
being able to ship at ambient rather
than needing dry ice
it also significantly simplifies the
workflow at point of use
all of the formulation has been done in
one big batch beforehand
and has been qc tested so
each one of the lyophilized pellets or
cakes
has the same activity and has already
been tested
the end user only has to add the sample
and then run the experiment
this means that the end user can run
multiple different tests
using exactly the same protocol by just
changing the loyalized cake
with a big batch size you only have to
run one qc for the entire batch
and your repeatability and reliability
of your save will be improved
and the the simplification of the
workflow at the point of use
also means that your
the waste is reduced
of not only the raw materials but also
of
plastic wear and tips there is less for
petting steps there is less threes
flooring of the enzymes
the mix you use on day one will be the
same as the mix you use on day five
so what type of assays can we lyophilize
most types
and if we've not done it we'll
definitely give it a go so we've done
lamp assays qpcr rt pcr
with that we've done many enzymes we've
done
rna for qc analysis and ngs
sequencing we've got a range of catalog
beads which do genomic fly and template
which are rolling circle amplifications
we've lyophilized conjugated mag beads
and we've also
started lyophilizing a range of exosomes
and biological reagents along those
lines
so how do you design your assay for
lowercalization three main points and
we're going to go through each of them
the first one is excipients second one
is formulation
the third one is what format you want to
put it in
cakes or beats so first
off the excipients now excipients are
very important for lyophilization for
two main reasons
one they provide the structure for the
cake which
aids in the reconstitution and also the
stability
but more importantly is they protect any
delicate
materials that are in the cake enzymes
and proteins have a complicated folding
structure
and in a solution this folding structure
is held in place
by the hydrogen bonds from the water
molecules during lyophilization you'll
be removing the water molecules
so you need to replace those into
intramolecular bonding with something
else
otherwise the protein is going to
denature and it's the excipients that
take over this
is it's the excipients that take over
this bonding and would
retain the activity of the enzymes
sativa has developed a range of
different
proprietary exhibits that are compatible
with many different applications
and have proven to be to give stable
product
one thing with the excipients is they
can create
the excipients can interfere with
your downstream assay so the
less excipients that we have to put into
the lyophilized cake the better the main
way we do this
is if you had a say 50 microliter pcr
we would dispense the reagents and
excipients in 10 microliters
we would lyophilize a 10 microliter cake
or a bead
and then at point of use it would be
reconstituted in 50 microliters
which would significantly decrease the
amount of excipient in the downstream
applications
the next important thing is the
formulation
you're about to spend hours removing all
the water from
the solution so as if you can
concentrate
some if you can concentrate the raw
materials and reduce the amount of water
you add you have a lot less water to
remove
things like changing primer
concentrations from 10 micromolar to one
millimolar
magnesium concentrations to one molar
and things like that
there is a limit to the amount you can
concentrate your reagents
and normally this is defined this
normally is limited by the salt
concentration
now as you know you they spread salt on
the rose to prevent it freezing
so increasing the salt concentration in
your assay will decrease the freezing
temperature
the long the more you decrease the
freezing temperature the harder it's
going to be to lyophilize
there are a few other things that
lyophilization can't cope with
the main one being glycerol so
for lyophilization we often have to
source either no glycerol or very high
concentration enzymes
so that we really limit the amount of
glycerol going into the solution
another solvent that we don't like is
dmso
and again too much dmso will prevent the
localization from being successful
as the plastic wear that is used to
lyophilize is also
very important when you think about the
cycle
the design whether or not the plastic
wear is going in the freeze dryer and
the shape of the plastic wear
will significantly impact the ability to
lyophilize
we also need to be able to properly seal
the plastic wet
so that after we've dried the cake we
can maintain that in a proper
environment
and we'll go into slightly more detail
about that later on
the next thing that we need to decide is
what format we want to end
now at sativa we have two formats which
we call
cakes and beads both of them use the
same proprietary excipient mix and probe
both of them use the same processes
the difference being the order at which
they are localized and put into plastic
ware
so for cakes we'll do the formulation we
will then dispense into the final
plastic wear
and then we will lyopulize in situ in
that plastic ware
with this method we put in the plastic
ware into the freezer so the plastic
needs to be able to
cope with the freeze drying cycle and
because of this our batch size is
limited to
about twenty thousand reactions for the
bead format
what we do is we do the formulation we
then drop and they form spherical beads
and we lay off the lies in those spheres
we then pick and place those beads into
the final plastic ware
and seal those and pack those our
typical batch size for beads is anywhere
from
5 000 to 350 000 reactions
so both formats and can use
pretty much any plastic wear tubes and
files that you'd like
that can be sealed
so going through stages of a freeze
drying cycle
so the first thing we need to do after
we put
the after we've done the formulation and
dispensed it
is to freeze the mix the this is
important because the next thing
the next step we're going to do is put a
vacuum and if the mix is not properly
frozen
then the vacuum will pull the liquid out
of the tube and
we will lose the entire cake one thing
we can do in the freezing step is to use
annealing steps which cycle between
solid and liquid this will form bigger
ice crystals
which would make drying easier the next
stage is primary dry
in this the vacuum is poured so it will
pull these
the conditions in the chamber below the
triple point
this causes ice to sublime from a solid
into a gas
and dries the that dries the cake
during this stage all of the unbound
moisture all of the unbound
water is removed from the cake
the length of the primary dry is very
dependent on the
height of the cake so the
the cake dries from the top down water
is removed from the top layer and then
as you can see in the second and third
pictures
the the cake proceeds downwards the tube
so tall thin cakes will take a lot
longer to dry
the temperature of which the primary dry
is set at will depend
on the salt concentration and the
formulation
in general higher salt concentrations
need lower temperatures to dry
the lower the primary dry and the
greater the vacuum that's pulled the
longer it will take to dry
after all of the bound water has been
sorry after all of the unbound water has
been removed in the primary dry
we then move on to the secondary dry a
lot of freeze dryers can have
endpoint determination tests at the end
of the primary dry
which will determine when this is so
they can be used to automatically extend
extend cycles when needed in the
secondary dry the temperature in the
chamber is raised
and the bound water is then removed
again at the end of this stage a lot of
freeze dryers can do
endpoint determinations and confirm that
no more water is coming off
after the cycle is finished the freeze
dryer then goes into a storage phase
this effectively stops anything else
from happening and allows the
cycles to be repeatable day after day in
the storage phase
the machine's basically just holding
everything in status until
it is ready to be unloaded
so you've just spent a day or two
removing all of the moisture from your
cake
we then need to pack it in a way that
it's going to maintain
its dryness and any extra water
any water that the cake absorbs is going
to
reduce its stability so the stability of
the cake comes from it being a solid
none of the reagents can move and start
interacting with each other
but any water ingress into the cake is
going to increase the mobility of the
reagents in there allowing degradation
or side reactions to start happening
so the primary seal that we put onto the
cake it can either be done in the freeze
dryer by means of collapsing shelves and
driving bungs into vials
or we can move them into either a
nitrogen box or a dry box
which are held at very low humidities so
under one percent humidity
and then we put a foil seal on
the cakes that then sealed we then pouch
into a desiccated foil pouch
with whatever label is the customer
requires on there
and this step is done in a room that's
held under 35
humidity so if stored in the sealed foil
pouch
then our typical stability is for well
over a year for custom products
so going on to a case study
so earlier on this year we there was a
company called
gene drive who are a point of care
diagnostic company
they came to us and asked us to help to
work with them to develop
a covert test that could be used in
labs around the world
so just going to talk through
in three months we managed to design
develop and then transfer
a covet assay
so for the first stage we sat down and
planned out the project with gene drive
with their requirements that the tests
would be
able to be used in labs worldwide this
meant that it would have to be able to
be used
in multiple different thermal cyclers
now a lot of different thermocyclers
have need different tube types and to
prevent
having to transfer from after they've
reconstituted
the cake or the bead we don't we did not
want to have to transfer
that reconstituted reagent into another
tube to be able to run
so this meant that we would have to
uh this meant that we would have to have
many different plastic wares for this
product
as it was a covered test the forecast
was also very big
and the demand would have been high
because of this we decided on the bead
format
now we the first steps we did were some
initial proof of principle runs in the
dedicated r d facility so at cardiff we
have
two facilities one set up one's
dedicated to r d
and one's dedicated to manufacture both
of which
have the same pretty much the same
equipment but the r d version slightly
smaller
so with gene drive gene drive designed
the
test and centers down the reagents we
lyophilized several different versions
of it sometimes in the same run
sometimes in
different runs took them out the freeze
dryer and sent them back up to gene
drive as quickly as possible
we then sit down and go through the
results with gene drive decide on the
next steps
so after several iterations we came upon
a formulation that we
was fixed we were happy with and we then
looked to transfer this into manufacture
so during the transfer process what we
wanted to do was ensure that we had a
robust product and that
it would we'd be able to manufacture it
day in day out
so we worked with gene drive and decided
that we would run three different
batches
and we'd slowly scale up from an r d
size run
to a manufacture size run now the
the idea of the product with gene drive
is that we would manufacture
one batch of bulk beads and these bulk
beads could be stored at sativa and then
dispensed into the plastic where needed
so there are four different types of
plastic wear depending on which
thermocyclers would need to be used
and we'd be able to use the one bulk one
batch of bulk bees to dispense into any
of these plate types
after we'd run the transfer runs we sat
down again with gene drive and confirmed
that
we were happy with the results they were
happy with the results
and that with the transfer have been
successful and this product was now
launched in manufacture
so currently it's in manufacture the
manufacturing team
run this regularly
and because of the the way the assay has
been designed
when gene drive have discovered that a
further form
plate type is needed then the
then it's a simple case of validating
the new ceiling methods for the plates
but the bog beats remain the same so we
can launch new products quickly
so to summarize gene drive came to us at
the beginning of the year
wanting to develop a cover test we
worked with them to streamline the tests
push it through our systems as quickly
as possible while covering everything
that we needed to cover
and we now have a reliable
and we now have a manufacturing product
which is suitable for
covet tests around the world in many
different thermocyclers
so we've got a couple of places where we
can get more information
there is a video which shows you our
live stable facility and takes you on a
tour around our lab
we've got a couple of papers that are
useful
and we've also got a form to
we also have a form for you to request a
proof of principle run
thank you very much and is there any
questions
thank you amy for the outstanding
presentation we will now move to the
live
q a portion of the presentation as a
reminder to the audience
please submit your questions via the q a
box
so let's take a look it looks like we
already have some great questions
coming in amy our first question
how long does it take for a proof of
principle to be run
so the first thing we'll do is work with
you
to decide on exactly what we want to
test
both what fits you best and what we can
run in one run and after we've decided
that and fully locked down
we will the aim is to have
samples shipping back out to you within
two weeks of receiving
your reagents on site for a standard run
if it's a larger run
and particularly if it's a bead run this
may be a bit longer
but we'll let you know beforehand if it
will be any longer
wonderful thank you and now how many
excipients
do you have so we do have a range of
excipients
we have uh eight standard ones if we
need them
typically we would start off with up to
four
depending on the type of assay we're
lyophilizing
and initially we test them wet and we
try
one or two in the first three first few
proof of principle runs
thank you so much our one audience
member
says i am iso one three four eight five
regulated can you manufacture our
products
yes we can so we are currently iso 9000
9001 regulated in cardiff
uh we are in the process of getting
13485 but we don't have it yet
and we do manufacture many 13485
products
thank you so much now how much does a
proof of principal
run cost so the
uh ethos of the custom team is not to
make any money of the proof of principal
runs
we will we look to cover our costs so
our proof of principal runs start
from as little as 1500 and
they go up depending on what the the
complexity of the pop and the number of
samples needed
thank you and i want to thank our
audience members for these great
questions
our next question is do we have to do
any validation
on ourselves as part of the proof of
principle
so for the proof of principles there
would be no validation that we would
need to do
however after the aim of the proof of
principles is to get a product into
manufacture
and as part of the manufacturing process
what we need to do is scale up so we
need to start
looking at things um like how we
dispense so in the proof of principle
runs we'll be dispensing
30 plates at a maximum properly
thank you so much is it possible
to arrange a site visit to the cardiff
site
yeah um normally um we say yes
at the moment we're doing a lot more
virtual tours so we can give you a
virtual tour of our site and we can do
virtual audits
and we can still welcome visitors if we
need to
um but normally yes it's we're very open
to visits
wonderful thank you we have time for one
more question what is the lead time
amy to secure a gmp run
so it does depend on the complexity of
the project
so and once we've started
once we've done all the proof of
principles and we have a lockdown
formulation
we will then start the transfer runs now
this can take anything from
six weeks to a couple of months or
longer depending on the complexity of
your project
and the urgency of which everything is
needed
and we'll take it through to the core
team so
once we've done the development we then
report our findings to the head of r d
head of manufacturer head of tech
support and between
us and working with yourselves the
customer we will develop
a action plan as to checking out all the
risks that we need
to look at before we can put this into
manufacture
once we've done the design transfer plan
and we've
validated everything that we've agreed
on we will then need to set it up in our
system
so it and so it is manufactured as a
full-on product
so it can be anything from a couple of
months to
a couple to longer depending on
complexity and amy this same audience
member wants to know
is it possible to get a copy of this
slide wheel of services
provided um we could
we have a copy of the information so in
our booth the
accelerating diagnostic development with
custom design services
there is a collection of web links one
of those for the custom
services for genomics is links to a web
page which has all the information that
was in that slide
wonderful amy thank you for your
presentation today and for your
important research
would you like to offer any closing
remarks to our audience before we go
just thank you for listening and if you
have any further questions
and please join me in the booth
amy thank you again amy webster and i
want to thank our audience members for
their participation
any questions that were submitted and
not answered today by our speaker will
be addressed
via email this presentation will be
available for on-demand
viewing for up to 12 months so please
remember to share it with your
colleagues who might be interested in
today's
topic and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab at the auditorium
for a full
listing thank you again for your
participation until next time take care
stay healthy and stay safe bye